all right guys bang-bang I've got
ondrea's here we were recording this on
a nice rainy day in New York City so
thanks for for braving it and coming on
hey folks cool man
we've gotten to know each other over the
last year or so a couple months whatever
it is I'm super intrigued by you are
probably one of the people who are most
bullish on remote work and kind of where
the world of work is going so maybe
let's just start with kind of your time
at producthunt and kind of that story
and then we'll get into you know where
the remote work focus came from mm-hmm
so quickly about my background that was
I did a bunch of stuff which is not that
interesting but lately I was the
founding part of the founding team of
Protandim site CTO there we sold to
Angelus roughly two and a half years ago
for the distributor team people from
pretty much most of the regions we
usually hired between West Coast and
Eastern Europe after we sold to Angel
list I joined for one year coinless the
crypto team did like VP of engineer and
since beginning of this year I kind of
focus on my main passion which is kind
of promoting remote work and the concept
and especially now as in a Bay Area it
becomes we have like this critical
moment where we have enough people
starting to understand that it's
actually a viable option and in many
cases even a better option so what I'm
kind of trying to do is my little part
to make it a little bit faster yep so
let's talk about product how the team
there worked because I think a lot of
people they kind of saw it as you know a
project not even a company at first and
then from afar looked like there was
this group of people who started all
just helping out right but nobody in the
beginning realized that I think Ryan
said multiple times that usually working
out of coffee shop right and kind of
people all over the world we're
contributing to this so talk a little
bit about how you got hooked up with the
with that founding team
and then kind of where'd the decision to
build a remote team versus kind of a
more centralized team and a single
office came from yeah so I think it's
pretty much spot-on the god of us belief
that this is a side project
when I joined like I was actually
working on my own startup and then ran
out of money like I literally forgot
that I had to pay taxes and I was like
okay I need to go back to freelancing
for a few months and then continue and
Ryan at that point was a bit of advising
and helping and it was so embarrassed
and I gave him a call and was like
that's bad you know I'm an idiot but I
will go a few months of freelancing make
some money and come back and he was like
do you mean we want to like help me a
bit because I think this is going
somewhere at some point I was like sure
but I don't think you can pay me but
it's fine I would work for free and or
like whatever you pay and on the side
work for clients who pay proper rate
weirdly enough I it was like from day
one constant like fire fighting and all
this kind of stuff and like we had like
a huge growth spurt in that time and I
never really got to work on any other
clients a few weeks later all of a
sudden he was like I think we can get
into YC you know I was like dude like no
I received my rejection from YC like a
few weeks ago they had they started the
cohort it's done you know like maybe
later and he was like no I think we can
get in two partners independent of each
other actually approached him about it
didn't know about the other one like
okay maybe we can consider get in so we
got into YC all of a sudden then he told
me I think it can raise money like okay
I spent so much time my life and not to
raise like messing up by raising money
and focusing on that instead of the
product and right now the product works
like let's focus on that and don't get
distracted like now I think I can raise
the median me like oh please no please
no not that again right now it's like
how much do you have even committed so
far he's like more than a million I'm
like okay I think we can raise hey so
all of a sudden this thing that all of
us believed to be a side project that we
really wanted to do had budget and we
could actually focus full-time on it
and at that point we were already remote
but more out of the fact that we got
everybody involved to kind of we liked
and was able to help and then I started
hiring some of the best people I know
which don't
happened to be in the same small city
and at some point I was like do we
actually do this intentionally or not or
like are we continuing this way and
because I already ran remote teams at
that point but it wasn't really like an
intentional decision at that point it
was more like an it happened because it
happened it was kind of like that's how
the setup was and we decided yes this is
an intentional decision we actually
managed to raise money from andreessen
horowitz at that point and I remember
like this we had like this internal
party where we like got a bunch of
people together celebrate the
fundraising and a friend of mine who's a
VC told me that Cadiz is amazing you
raised some money now you can get an
office and get everybody over and
finally become a real company I was like
okay that's maybe maybe no maybe we are
already a real company and oddly enough
the same friend is now promoting remote
work on Twitter so I think we're now at
this tipping point where it's kind of
like becoming a word for the Silicon
Valley area that's usually living in
their own bubble yeah so let's talk a
little bit about two things right so one
is you backed into one of the best
pieces of advice I ever got which was if
you keep your personal burn rate low
enough you can always accept
opportunities that maybe can't pay you
as much in the short term but long term
can be quite lucrative or valuable and
so when you said to Ryan hey I'll work
for whatever you can pay me and then
I'll kind of figure out how to make
money you know the rest of of my time it
really allowed you to you know could I
grab an opportunity rather than if you
had said hey look I gotta get paid you
know a hundred thousand dollars and I
have cover from this big corporate job
and you just you can't afford me and we
talked a little bit about you know had
you always spent your life you know kind
of with that mindset or was it more just
serendipity and that's how I ended up I
think I was an unfortunate position at
that point because we completely tanked
our previous startup and I had like a
huge summer between Barnard and midlife
crisis so very fortunate position to be
in because it also allowed me to I
literally sold everything I had and had
like one piece of luggage where
everything was in and I was constantly
like living between cities I know that
are cheap and like for exactly trying
out new stuff I was like trying out new
projects and all this kind of so by
default there was
really cheap at that point it was a
ridiculously cheap if I look now back
and like look at my excellent sheets
from back then I'm like how did this
even work like how did I get enough
nutrition you know like how did like
would cities huh would cities that was
Berlin back then Berlin yeah but back
then Berlin was ridiculously affordable
nowadays it's a bit more expensive but
like still and honestly I think I could
not have done it if I wouldn't have been
that dirt cheap at that point that being
said when you grow up when you get like
a family and everything is like a little
bit different of obviously like more
responsibility and everything but I
think the general fact here is true like
if you have if you manage to be on a no
burn rate you have more opportunity and
that would always be true especially for
founder's got it and then the second
thing is this balance between focusing
on fundraising and kind of taking a
bunch of time away from that of building
the product or just focus on building
the product it feels like again as I
watch this kind of play out from afar
you guys focused on the product the
product took off and people really liked
it and then the fundraising interest
came in bound race you spend time going
outbound and taking a bunch of meetings
etc it was more of you built something
people wanted and investors recognized
that and then they can beat the door
down to invest it was the complete
opposite like the start about it before
we managed to raise around another 1.5
million or so and we need with very big
light in Europe and we got like every
bad advice that you can give to a team
we did literally everything wrong we had
at some point we had a business plan
like nobody writes a business plan but
like we had a business plan in two
different languages we had a financial
model that could do balancing and like
the craziest stuff we had multiple pitch
decks multiple variations that was so
good in like pitching it in so many
different ways but we didn't spend
enough time on actually building the
product because we were a kind of advice
to focus on that you know so and that in
comparison to product and again the
first startup we had an answer for any
question of the VC my dancer I Mike Mike
Oscar's but literally any question
answered we had at some point we had a
flow chart where our whole process back
then we produced garments for in
vertical integrated e-commerce store and
we had a flow chart at Express
our process which was four meters long
and but like on a font that's barely
readable there's a photo with me next to
this flowchart and the future is roughly
more than twice my size and a product
and we I experienced what the difference
is if you have actual attraction it like
traction literally solves every problem
especially when it comes to fundraising
and we were in this ridiculous position
to be the one hyped company at Y
Combinator back then and anybody who has
ever been to my comedy there's always
like one or two companies that stand out
in that patch you know and if you're one
of those you literally get overrun with
offers to invest for sure and part of
the traction solves everything it's just
there's an inevitability of success
right so that's where the hype in the YC
batch comes it's like no of course
they're gonna win right and so employees
want to work their partners wanna you
know work with that company investors
want to invest and and it definitely
reduces the friction to building a
company but you still have to stay
disciplined and focused right so it's
not just oh you've got a little bit of
traction in the beginning guaranteed
you're gonna win
it really does come down to can you
figure out how to you know to kind of
scale the product and continue to build
a product that people want know without
getting distracted absolutely and the
other thing which most people don't tell
you it's it's extremely terrifying
like I remember regularly looking at our
charts everything going up to the right
and it was like I don't do anything
different right now or at least I feel I
don't do anything different with the
companies were nothing worked so maybe I
have absolutely no control over this and
maybe it stops tomorrow and I don't know
how to make it start again and sometimes
you unlock something but you understand
your actual growth mechanic and later on
we managed to do that but early on it
was kind of like jumping in and just
keeping this thing afloat and just like
like swimming with it as much as we can
and to be frank this is this is
terrifying in a way especially early on
it's a good in terrifying and maybe in a
good way but still and the other thing
which I didn't know back then and now
that I invest myself a little bit more a
lot of investors actually just try to
get into this deal
to do like sticker collecting you know
just proof that they have access and
Milo goes by logos exactly and it's kind
of almost like to this point like there
used to be this saying like nobody ever
got fired for buying IBM or something
like that you know and it feels almost
like with a lot of VCs it's kind of like
getting to the hype deals especially if
you're found isn't that credible yet you
know that like one number one thing to
build up credibility you have these
logos and all this kind of stuff so
sometimes it's less about a judgement
about you even then it's a judgement
about the current moment of VC and
nowadays that I'm investing myself a
kind of seeded back then I was kind of
like head of the blind for a founder POV
almost on it yeah in the part to me that
around this terrifying feeling right is
I've got a part of a couple of products
or companies where they've just
absolutely exploded in growth right you
know hitting the tops of whether it's
the App Store or some other you know
metrics that are pretty identifiable and
quantifiable you want to continue to
iterate and improve the product but you
also don't want to mess it up yep right
and so it's like hey look this is
working how far do we actually go to
improve it versus if we make a change it
could hinder that growth and then the
second thing is I always joke about you
don't understand what you describe is a
terrifying feeling until literally the
server's are like melting right and
there and it's literally growing so fast
that it feels like you have to keep
spitting up you know but there's AWS
instances or whatever to actually keep
this thing working because you don't
have the pleasure and kind of the
benefit of having all the systems in
place of a larger company you don't have
the headcount so you have to do things
that I think is more kind of scrambling
to keep things together which on the
outside looks like wow that company's
growing really fast on the inside people
aren't sleeping there's a lot of kind of
stress right all that stuff's going on
so I'm assuming that that's what you
guys were dealing with too and then you
add on the remote layer on top of it
yeah absolutely
the other thing is also in my opinion
there are teams that scale with a code
base that wasn't meant to be scaled and
there are teams who don't scale and
there's almost nothing in between
and we also had this like in the
beginning and most of our problems were
homemade they were just like we didn't
do our homework properly we didn't have
the time right and so we constantly had
like performance problems for like
completely in things that can be done
properly what we didn't have a time for
it so yeah it's it's that I highly
recommend I wish everybody in the world
has one like this 15 minutes of
ridiculous growth you know in the future
it's a very important experience to
learn it also kind of like lets you
learn a little bit about what are the
things that you actually need to have
under control
so what we did extremely aggressive was
a be testing a lot we did a lot of likes
feature flag rollouts a lot of dog
launches a lot of better testing we with
it was to the point that we shipped we
tried to really like very aggressive
shipping cycle we had we basically had
this idea of having public announcement
about new features and products every I
think back then it was two weeks two and
a half weeks something like that with
the idea of like even if product feature
a doesn't work right now we wanted
something else to kind of show to give
this expressive feeling of hype as well
to keep this going right so we were very
aggressive about that and I remember at
some point we we tried out features and
products which were literally just a
link and the type form you know and just
to see if there's something and then if
yes double down on it and we had so many
of those in peril and I personally think
this is how I need startup should
operate nowadays yeah it's the narrative
right it is that inevitability of
success and I recently saw a number of
venture capitalists on Twitter talking
about like the way that you raise
capital with a deck they were talking
about is around the narrative so the
world exists in this way today we're
going to do this thing after we do this
thing the world's gonna change and
here's what's gonna look like in the
future what you guys were doing I think
was you were iterating so quickly and
there was this feeling of like even
though is only every two weeks it felt
like every day there was an announcement
right just because it was happening so
rapidly and you could quickly see
and kind of let your mind expand into
what could this become right so is this
today just a way to discover products
could one day they help with hiring
because they help with this and then and
you really kind of saw the test as if
you were paying attention hey they're
testing to figure out where the demand
is and then when you would find it it
seemed like within weeks you would roll
out the actual you know functional
product and and then that was a whole
nother part of the business that you
know didn't exist just a couple weeks
ago yes right talk about the experience
of combining forces with AngelList and
kind of what the with the logic there
was so the interesting thing with
angellist was that they were culturally
and like by their goal as a company very
much aligned with us so angel is that
this overall mission of following the
arc of a start-up so you're kind of like
you find your co-founders you have an
idea you launch you raise money you hire
people and you sell the company at some
point and Angeles is very much like
trying to help startups with all the
high impact moments of this journey so
protocol was kind of like this moment
and then you launch and that was kind of
like this part that really fit well and
one thing that we always were like
struggling with it so we we monetized
through subscription we monetized
through ads and all this kind of stuff
and we were like in a good shape that we
didn't basically die by default but we
were always like okay technically the
biggest angle to this would be through
investment and this kind of like
basically monetizing the hype and all
this kind of stuff is like into
investments and all these kind of things
so for us the whole partnership or merge
with angellist came almost like kind of
natural I was originally actually
against it because I was like no we
raised more money and we go like go
crazy looking back this was actually the
best thing we could do at that point
because team was and culture wise the
team's overlap really well and a lot of
the people who were producthunt now lead
teams in AngelList
and and so on and so on so I think it's
a I think this was like one of the best
decisions with it as a company easily
the the interesting thing that I also
believe is what's kind of like shows how
good is the fittest it's like how many
people of producthunt in the end also
like started their own fund many of them
through tools that AngelList provides so
I think there's like a very very well
Alliant culture and people fit for sure
and so you today serve as the head of
remote at AngelList describe a little
bit about what that is and then we can
get into some of the actual advice
around remote work yeah so technically
it's so that they did the amazing thing
about this title is that nobody knows
what this title is supposed to mean and
by now I actually just keep it because
it's so confusing it's it's kind of like
it sounds big right I think a better
title looking back would have been head
of remote products so AngelList has the
largest job board for startups and it's
also the largest job board for remote
work in startups but barely anybody
knows and it's a there's a lot of
functionality that just doesn't work
well with remote teams so my job is
basically to make sure we align the
product into the right direction that it
actually works for remote teams and
remote candidates really well and so
it's actually more like head of remote
products right and this whole angle of
like being in charge of the remote
culture of a company which a lot of
people associate if it's actually what I
not really I'm not really paid for that
you know that's not my job nowadays what
I actually think is even though if I
don't do the job of a head of remote
that like this cultural aspect I believe
that's a very valid job for a lot of
larger teams that are either remote or
remote first and for example at gitlab
there is Darren who is not a head of
remote there whose main job is to make
sure that internally divert more and
more efficient and it works for
everybody that like any learning they
have at some part of the company can
transition to the rest of the company's
order that the team works best possible
way all remote got it and so let's get
into kind of why is this becoming so
popular right there's this idea of
remote work I think a lot of folks would
say remote work is the equivalent of the
future of work and we're seeing really
the startups I think have kind of
pioneered here now your stakes in a
larger come
jump in as well but just like what's the
what's driving this trend is it more
technological is it societal is it a
mixture of things so personally I think
there's nothing particularly new about
this what happened now is more than the
big tech hubs that usually were very
bullish on having everybody in the same
place and that's mainly San Francisco
Bay Area a little bit New York that they
are now like as seeing as an an
alternative and they now have enough the
VCS especially now have enough as it's a
data point to have alternative pattern
recognition in like okay this can
actually also produce a large company
that github get labs save here there's a
kind of data points yet again basically
they can apply the typical pattern
matching now and that is more what
changed is that it's more like why it's
perceived now as like as a hype topic
and I also think we are now in a weird
moment of time where it's perceived as a
thing I'm pretty sure in four years from
now we like we couldn't have a podcast
about remote work it would be kind of
like talking about smartphones you know
it's like why do you call it smart phone
it's just a phone and the same way been
for years like what are your code remote
work is just work I just happen to work
for company in Boston you know and if
you look at the underlying trends more
people working online more people
working intelligent digital knowledge
work and more people working
internationally with international teams
all of that have the logical conclusion
that remote working circuit by default
and I think we're now at this point
where we don't even even if we think we
work non remote we actually most of the
time already work remote so many people
are checking their email on the way to
work or working on Friday from a coffee
shop are working when they are like on a
business trip and working like
all-nighters or whatever there and
technically all of that used to be
called telecommuting and all of that
technically is remote work so we're now
switching actually from an binary
equation of like remote or yes or no to
more like a spectrum where it's no
longer about are you working remote or
not it's more like on this to paducah
rid of how far away are you from the
next hub like the next headquarter and
how these to be with your team is across
time zones of the people you work with
so basically house are synchronous to
your work so axis one is basically how
easy would it for you to be
come to come to a headquarter and X is
to is like how asynchronous is the team
you're working in and I think this will
be more the discussion in the future so
the discussion will be more like like
how asynchronous do you want this team
to be do you want to hire people in more
than let's say five to eight hours of
timezone difference this is something
you actually want to aspire to you think
notice is like going to kill our
productivity there's a mode teams that
require everybody like invasion requires
everybody to work on Eastern time zone
you know and that by default excludes a
lot of people there's most remote teams
only higher in their own country
American remote teams are notorious for
only hiring in the US and best case in
Canada most remote teams are actually
best case hiring in their own time zone
roughly you know so there's a lot of
already now like this this it's almost
like a spectrum discussion area now and
I think that's it's like where it's
going and we're kind of like in this
weird moment of time where remote work
is kind of like a concept that we still
intentionally can talk about and then in
future we'll be much more like okay I
have people in different time zones and
I have to find ways that the synchronous
work works better we will focus more on
these angles got it and so as you get
into the remote work I agree with you
that you know four five years from now
it's just be work but there's a lot of I
want to say fear but kind of tepid ation
in terms of people just immediately
going from 100% centralized everyone
comes to do an office to let's say a
hundred percent remote right and so a
lot of this is around building up
business and what I want to do spend
some time just on the actual advice of
if I'm a entrepreneur or a manager and I
want to start either bring on people
into a remote work kind of scenario or I
want to build my team a hundred percent
remote things like you know how do you
see people running meetings right so
that's kind of like an easy one where
yeah there's conference calls and things
like that but if you have folks who are
in different geographies different time
zones etc you can't get everyone to walk
into the same conference you know table
and
and hold a meetings like what are some
of the best practices you see there in
terms of just meetings for remote teams
I think one of the important parts is
here to understand where you currently
are on the company like if you think of
like a spectrum line or whatever and
where you want to be and so for example
the typical problem is hybrid setups you
know and that can be eight people in the
office and two people in that team not
being in the office and trying to call
in into the meeting and then pretty much
being like screwed right like it's hard
to understand everybody you're
constantly out of the looping
communication etcetera it's kind of like
second-class citizen second-class
citizens and that's what a lot of people
associate with remote work and the
problem you have here is that if you're
in the office it's very very easy to
talk about something and very annoying
to write something down if you're remote
it's very easy for you to write
something down it's very annoying to
like talk synchronously about something
at least for a longer time so what's
happening it's not that like one is
better than the other it's just on
different communication layers by
default so what you need to be in the
for example in the hybrid team is even
it be very intentional about the bridge
between this and the problem is that
humans will always tend to the thing
that's easy
they will always go for the thing that's
like there's more approachable and
easier and like basically we all are
lazy by default so there you need to be
a little bit more aware of that the Ida
by discipline and discipline usually
doesn't work for most people
or by setup and for example in hybrid
teams what I recommend if for example if
the whole company isn't remote first or
isn't all remote have a critic like have
sub teams we're in this sub team a
critical amount of people is remote so
that this team needs to work remote
first that day by default do their
discussions in like hangout calls and
not over a table that they by default
need the process will be optimized for
the majority of the team versus of the
two people who happen to be in the
office so for example you it's very
common that you have your infrastructure
team remote that you have your customer
care team erode like and this kind of
like sub team approach works really well
because that way you get like the
learnings you can bring into the rest of
the company other things here is if you
cannot do that for example because if
exam you need to do like your all hand
meeting where the extra majority of
people happens to be in the office or
the I highly recommend is half the
people
who do talk Colin so that everybody's on
the same communication layer that
everybody can ask questions the same way
that everybody hears and understands the
same way so if you know that there will
be like two or three people who give a
presentation or like who will talk
discuss something the majority of the
time have these people call in so that
you have the same layer for everybody
and there's a few other lyrics there in
the office even if they're in the office
I know I know teams were it's literally
like everybody goes into the meeting
room and like two people go into the
phone booth you know and that's my
intention and that's I think creates a
better culture internally got it and the
tools that you see people using phones
say these meetings that involve folks
that are remote whether 100 percent or
some in the office Google Hangouts
obviously I'm assuming is a big one of
their other tools that you see people
using that you think are pretty positive
so in general I think most teams don't
have a tool problem I think most teams
have a process problem we used to have
Skype and HipChat I know that email and
that worked good enough now we have
slack consume you know and email and it
works good enough you know there is in
reality more process problem that being
said there is always like a little bit
of iteration around tooling and like
there's always like lessons to be
learned like what I'm a big fan of is
like recording meetings and then having
gotten automated like while you take
notes life you automatically are
timestamp to two parts in that video
there's like rained out coal that does
like something like that there's a few
other companies that do that a big fan
of that kind of approaches but in
general it's much more about like having
a process so for example it needs to be
important that somebody takes notes it
needs to be important that's not like
that it's very clear what the decisions
afterwards are very clear what like who
is the action who like takes the action
item like who owns it and so on and so
on and that necessary is nothing to do
with remote work that's just management
101 the problem you have in most remote
teams is you can't as easily monkey
patch or like hotfix
bad management like in a bad processes
in in in a co-located office if you have
a bad process about something and
there's constantly people a little bit
unclear you just I don't know quickly
talk about it in a meeting and like come
on a sec same page and then you're
dispersed you can't that easily do that
in a remote team so what you end up
doing is you are
thinking about more intentionally about
your processes and which in general is
good but if you're like yet super small
and early you know you need to be
careful not to over engineer those
processes so otherwise you're basically
you're slowing down because of that
obviously for sure and you know what
we've talked about so far as with
synchronous meetings where everyone's
there at the same time I know that
there's some remote teams who either
through time zone there's no preference
they feel a need or want to hold a
synchronous meetings meaning that how do
we share information and communicate but
we're not there all at the same time
what have you seen there is kind of the
way people are doing that or doing it
well this is like the one thing where I
think currently the most iteration is
happening in print in tooling and
product it's usually much more around
proposals and documents and like having
specific communication around those and
coming together like co-create document
and that's usually what's happening or
more and there's multiple teams who have
like all the folks distributed
everywhere and some of them do it
religiously like duyst is one of them I
would say more aggressive ones that have
all the team anywhere what I noticed
though is in most of those teams most of
those companies that are extremely
distributed even those teams that sub
teams who work with together a lot tend
to be roughly in the same time area or
like roughly five hours overlap three
hours overlap verse case so like some
overlap has to happen so like the mobile
team maybe or whatever team or like the
management team leadership team they're
roughly in the same time zone area
because it's just you otherwise lose too
much time around this the other
counterintuitive thing is like I highly
recommend that remote teams we meet as
much as possible if you like you have a
sub team and you have a project kickoff
a larger one like get everybody together
you have a company and that you you
figure out that you pretty much hit the
wall with something get everybody
together even if you're in person even
if you have nothing and it's just like
celebrate or or not even that like just
being human get everybody together like
do offsites quarterly half year whatever
you can do that by itself is usually the
biggest lever for any
this program in reality for sure and
then in terms of how do you think about
documenting information and sharing
information so not as so a meetings
right where you and I need to talk but
more around this process stuff right so
I'm going to put notes into the code
right but I also have non-technical
areas of process or commenting etc like
how do you see teams doing that today
so do the biggest learning I had here is
for example as an engineer you know that
you are building your code to support
whatever you have now and that in six
months if this thing actually scales if
the thing is actually worth your time
you will refactor the parts that face
problems you might even refactor all of
it but usually you refactor the parts
that have problems and that's also true
for management you are if your company
is growing you will refactor how you
work every six months like as I'm rough
now in a nutshell so whenever you feel
like you hate process problems you hate
that the fact that people are misaligned
you will hate to hate the fact that
there's communication problems there is
constantly misunderstandings or whatever
all of these kind of problems don't go
away they're just getting replaced by
other process problems on the long run
and you just need to accept that almost
and need to basically say okay what it
works for now what is good enough for
now do that make it explicit that's the
most important part like make it
explicit to the point that the things
that your team already is doing it
should be a word this is like we do this
intentionally and these two or three
things we don't like we don't care this
much like if you want to do them do them
you know but like these few corals we
expect you to do make this very explicit
and when you start like wait for
problems to happen and then you start
seeing those problems to actually pop up
and cause trouble try to address these
specific problems individually and again
like refactor only that part of the
process one of the biggest risks that
you can do as a company is kind of like
mentally masturbate about like how your
company should operate and they come off
this really really complex answer for
every question that might ever be asked
like this big can't looks
flowchart I mentioned in the beginning
right and do that for processes that's
the biggest and like that's the easiest
way to wreck your company my experience
for sure
and you mentioned management right that
kind of I know you've given a number of
talks on like managing a remote how does
that differ from managing a non remote
team so personally I think that remote
teams have I usually say like 5x the
process needs and I say 5x the process
needs because it sounds really nice in a
tweet in reality it's more like I would
say 3x but that doesn't sound that
retweet able but main thinking here is
if you are a team of let's say five you
roughly act as if we would be a team of
15 to 25 people in a co-located team if
you're a team of like ten people in a
remote setup or remote setup you roughly
act as if you would be 30 to 50 and that
goes on and at some point you hit like
this logarithmic scaling point where if
you are like 200 400 people you don't
work as if you would be more than 1,000
or something like that and so in reality
you have like a little bit more
awareness around processes and you need
to be I think like the biggest learning
here for me was like you you manage
processes and you lead people versus you
manage people and I think this is the
biggest learning I had here so you kind
of like want to get to the point that
people can self manage to make decisions
on their own alright so explain this you
said you manage processes but you lead
people a berate on that so your job as a
manager is to define the processes and
like how you expect people to work
internally and process isn't like this
this huge chain where 20 people have to
hand over something like we have this
very negative connotation with the word
processing startup is almost like a word
people try to avoid a process just means
explicit expectation so for example in
an engineering team I might expect that
the people when they start working the
first thing they do is that they review
code of other people and I expect him to
do that before they do their own stuff
and the reason I expect him to do that
is so for example that other people are
as unblocked as early as possible right
so if you have people working across
multiple time zones that will always
somebody who has revealed your code
before you come back next day right and
that's an explicit expectation that
that's not that complex handover that's
just an explicit expectation that's a
process and these kind of processes you
want as few as a few as possible you
know but very very explicit and
everybody in your team needs to be aware
like what are your expectations and you
regularly need to tune them reengineer
them like you basically figure out that
some of them don't work for you anymore
your team scaled now it's like too hard
for you now to review every code you
know like now how do you prioritize here
how do you expect people to make that
and it's again I can make this
expectation explicit and so in reality
as a manager you manage processes you
did your job as a manager is not to make
decisions your job if it's manager is to
figure out together with your team what
decisions need to be done who does them
and make sure these decisions are made
and ideally you want the most capable
person in your team to make the decision
wherever they're most capable about and
to have a process where this person is
actually enabled to make these decisions
run with these decisions that's your job
as a manager so you need to set up a
team where everybody can actually run
with the problems they'd like to run if
the promising solutions they have been
are enabled to actually do that and what
we call what I usually call optimizing
for single player mode so they need to
be able to run the game on their own and
it doesn't mean like never work with
anybody else but not being dependent on
other people unless they want to imagine
you're running Mario and you press jump
and all of a sudden it's okay thank you
for pressing jump please wait until the
other person comes online this would not
be a very popular game for a Nintendo so
the goal is like how can you be at
autonomously as possible and then pull
in people for quality work and put pull
people in for things where you actually
want to pull them in and this is kind of
like your job as a manager comes in like
how can you enable people to do that and
did the sad truth here is as a manager
every problem in your company every
mistake that anybody does is ultimately
your fault and so it's it's very easy to
blame your engineering team if something
goes wrong to blame whoever if something
like blame your CTO if something goes
wrong if
you're in some way of fashion and we
have this weird term of like being above
somebody right like if you're managing
them that area somehow it's ultimately
your fault
because you either did not create the
right context for those people to
succeed you did not hire the right
people you did not fire the wrong people
it's in some ways form or fashion your
own fault and that's kind of the thing
that you need to learn as a manager what
you're talking about is really giving
people the autonomy to do the things
they think are best right you have to
really trust them they've got to
essentially be successful on their own
and you add up all those individual
successes it makes the team successful
but that's all built on the premise that
you hire the right people right and so
how do you think about any changes to
the hiring process when teams are remote
given this kind of more you know
autonomy driven work style versus maybe
if they were coming into an office is
there a change so I think about this a
lot actually because ahead of remote
products at Angeles right she doesn't
have all the answers yeah I hope at some
point like in five years maybe my so my
biggest learning here is actually that
kind of if you hire across bigger
regions usually your typical hiring
pattern recognition breaks down so you
might not know the university this
person went to you might not know the
company that worked for you don't know
you might even struggle understanding
cultural differences you know like while
is this person what does this person
look pissed off all the time in this
call you know and that's just no
Germanic person yeah III yeah that's
just me you know whereas resting
[ __ ] you know it's just like you
struggle maybe with these little
differences and especially if example if
you used to hiring in tech cups it kind
of breaks down if people don't follow
these patterns my number one lesson
learnt here is give them actual work and
see how they actually work so that can
mean for example for engineers that can
mean give them a small project that you
pay for you know or two pair programming
together with them you know okay we
combine them like let them do a small
project and then later on - one hour
more
programming where you asked him to
extend this little thing with another
little thing you know so you actually
see how they work and this is true for
engineering this is true for marketing
this is true for every area and in my
experience this works best
I know teams that go as far like that
flow is notorious for this they do
interviews that are more about figuring
out if this person would be a good
cultural like people fit you know and
then afterwards they literally just pay
this person to work with them for a week
and after the week they give them an
offer which is in my opinion crazy
because who can take off a week and just
like work at some other company to see
if they want to like work there you know
but it works for them really well and is
that part of the test okay are you
willing to take a week off or do you
think that's just maybe maybe not you
know they also offer and by the way this
is like half a year old information
maybe to change this but they also do
this thing where you can do two hours in
the evening and work with them two hours
a day for like literally a month and in
their experience the people who do this
like over a month are almost like a
definite higher all the time you know
and who actually managed to do this for
a month and I I get it like if I do this
for a month I'm committed I want to join
right and it works really well for them
this is an extreme case you know but you
can't do this like no file like I
strongly believe in remote work on phone
contract for hire give somebody a
project like work with them on something
real you know and agree on a rate that's
not like their extreme amount of
freelancing and it's not like as low as
like the full time hiring broken down to
a few days you know but somewhere in
between so it's fair for both sides if
it works put a contract afterwards as
part of this so this kind of project
based hiring does this work both for
technical teams and non-technical hires
or is it more technical focus so I
primarily hired technically in my life
so I can properly tell but I know people
who do similar stuff for sales roles and
marketing roles where they basically
give them a typical toss that would
happen in in their company you know and
seems to work quite well what are some
of the biggest mistakes you've seen on
the employee side right so we've talked
a lot about kind of man
but if you're that person in the remote
team who's sitting there's no one in
your city right that work at your
company so you're fully remote 100% of
the time what are some of the mistakes
you make or the things that you can do
to actually make the team work better
right because you've sat in that seat
before like what were some of the things
that you did either good or bad that you
think people should should be aware of
there's multiple things like one angle
is like in the end you're a manager of
one like you need to manage yourself you
know and that goes that starts with like
understand when you went and how your
most productive how you actually see a
human being operate there's people who
like to get up at 6:00 a.m. work for a
few hours go to the gym and then work
for a few hours you know there's people
who like to work in the evening and like
I understand that part you know there is
the angle of I personally do not
recommend working from home there's a
lot of people doing that and doing it
very successful if you work from home
get a dedicated area for that you know I
personally what I recommend is rent a
small office together with a few friends
who also work remote because for me at
least this is what I personally prefer
because it creates this separation
between work and rest and I also have
not as distracting as a co-working space
you know but not as isolating as being
completely only at home and I especially
with like a little bit of an ADHD I have
a problem of setting boundaries so it
literally could happen that I will get
up in the middle of night and continue
working on something or if my desk as it
used to be it's like next to my living
room I will constantly do that so that
kind of like management of one on the
management of teams it's super important
that you you kind of like this whole
thing about like understanding where
processes break down and like trying to
fix them it's also like in a part a
co-owned responsibility of every
employee in reality every effective team
has people who are very very intentional
about their own productivity very
intentional about the team productivity
and do not expect other people's to just
fix it you know at least figure out like
how it could be improved and do all
these kind of things it's
there is no magic bullet solution to
this because every company as they scale
has completely different needs and
process different complete different
needs as a company also like different
tip people when they work together have
completely different need so there's no
like magic silver bullet there's more
like this general responsibility of this
individual people yeah
and I guess the idea of if me you and
you know three or four friends all work
promote four separate companies coming
together into an office space one
there's a kind of economic argument for
right two is more when I would consider
like the psychological argument of just
separating work and rest and all that
but three is also that there's probably
a huge benefit because I get a see you
know how are you interacting with this
remote team and what are your best
practice is what tools are you using etc
absolutely I a friend of mine he's he's
working for a company one and a half
days a week and it works really really
well and I don't know how he's doing it
and I'm trying to learn that no I I
really don't understand it but it works
really well what's he do the rest of the
week I'm trying to figure out a lot of
open-source so I think it's that you
know but whenever he comes to that
office he's working with a gruffly one
or two days so yeah people work very
different it's very important to learn
for that yeah for sure
what um as you started to to do more
investing obviously one of the themes
that you're really excited about or
maybe that the major theme is this
remote work as there's a lot of people
building tools a lot of people building
products for this space like what are
the themes that you think either one or
important or two are where the value is
going to be created over next you know
five ten years so for context I recently
announced remote first capital which is
basically me plus right sixty people
right now seventy people may be
investing together in startups that
either improve remote work or leverage
remote work in a unique way and the
interesting thing when it comes to that
is a lot of people think instantly about
communication tools and I me too like in
collocation tools is obviously an
important one but it's almost like the
most boring thing you can invest in when
it comes to remote work right now
and then why is it so boring it's just
there's like a lot of other opportunity
we're right now in this moment where we
have access to global highly skilled
talent and we're like almost like in a
very fortunate time right now there's
enough international talent working
globally and not enough companies
actually leveraging that so you can
create really really new angles to
multiple problems right now and this is
nothing that's crazy future out there
discussion right now nowadays if you go
to a hospital and you do an x-ray
there's a high chance that this actually
won't be looked at at the office at your
deal at the hospital it will be looked
at like somewhere else by some people
who specialize on that you know and
that's normal by now and there's I
strongly believe that remote work is
like we're thinking of this tech angle
you know there's multiple other angles
like larger classical enterprises
bringing their operations remote
governments bringing the administration
job and operations remote what currently
is happening is everything is polarizing
towards single few hubs worldwide so to
the point that these single hubs are
more important than the rest of the
country like I know a lot of people who
move to New York but don't think of
moving to the USA or like move to San
Francisco and don't like or move to Bali
and so on and so on I get to the point
that this individual hub becomes more
important than the rest of the area
which leaves the question is like what
happens to all the other regions what
happens to all the small towns small
villages and all these kind of areas
everywhere and remote work isn't an
interesting answer to that and there's
like the whole concept about like local
remote so you have an somebody a hub in
a small town where they do like for
example it's like in traditionally like
an oil hub and they bring their
operations administration's to the
region around so that not everybody has
to commute to a one-hour or something to
the main office what can work most of
the time from home and so but III
strongly see like a strong angle here
and I believe this
for example GU arbitrage which we
usually associate with outsourcing but
just by the fact that there is better
and different talent worldwide
I believe there will be a lot of
interesting unique things coming up
another thing is like flexibility so you
recently got a kid you have for example
you are currently studying or you you
have a disability and you need like to
adjust your work life to that and I
think remote work would become the
default angle to that I recently invest
in a company that offers 10 hours a week
work placements basically internships
fully remote in marketing and the idea
is that you as a student need practical
experience as early as possible the
other angle here is like if credentials
globally break down if you don't know
how to evaluate somebody from Nigeria or
from somebody from Latin America or even
from the rest of the USA if they don't
didn't go to Stanford you know how do we
actually evaluate them I one company
invested in this doing chopped
applications through pull requests so as
an engineer you literally get access to
the backlog of a company in a code
sandbox environment and you can do small
tasks focusing and showing actually hey
I'm a useful contribute contributor and
at that point the company knows nothing
about you they don't know your your skin
your face your gender nor your
background you're nothing the only if
you've seen your code and there's a
multiple angles to that other big aspect
here I think there's a billion dollar
company easily built if not multiple the
whole concept around global payroll and
global benefits and I think that's kind
of like the stripe opportunity of our
generation
when stripe came and I ran an e-commerce
company at that point it kind of came
into a market where you're either we're
working with local shitty providers and
multiple of them in a very complex
painful process all you've worked with
some few suppliers that are
internationally and global that are just
hard to work with as a start-up and
there was almost nothing in between
properly and stripe came and made it one
click and like focused on the experience
convenience all this kind of stuff
and made it really eat like simplified
or reduce that whole complexity for you
as a user and I believe in payroll of
benefits there is a billion-dollar
company easily in
area the and there's multiple angles to
that there's this whole angle in remote
work if if I can for example act let's
not think about like engineering but
let's think of customer care so for
example I want to on board on a team and
I have a few tools to use and I have
like my cockpit I almost like download
this thing and I have all my SAS tools
in there and it is like a company also
reasoned investment they're doing that
but like the bigger angle here could be
on the long run what if in the morning I
get up and I have like five or eight
different companies I technically work
from I work for and I just pick the
tasks that currently fit into my day and
do those and it becomes almost like an
fluid marketplace and there's like a lot
of decentralized concept encrypt around
this this is like a huge angle to me
personally as well and and so on and so
on I can talk about forever for this
knows what else yeah I think they're a
bunch I have literally a huge list of
companies I actually want to invest in
and if I don't find them then I would
build them on my own
it feels like the biggest if we believe
also like one of the biggest
opportunities we have right now is in
private equity going all remote and I
say this with knowing almost next to
nothing about private equity so please
correct me at any point yeah and just to
clarify here because I know that is
something we want to spend a lot of time
on private equity in this sense is not
like private investing meaning venture
capital as it comes being built this is
much more taking a company that already
exists and trying to scale it grow it I
come in I buy your company and then here
we go right yes alright good so we right
now I have a wife and I I highly
recommend somebody let some listeners
hear please do that let me know I want
to if there's a way I can invest in the
private equity I don't know if I legally
can do that but like I want to do that
so there is this right now this face
where we have VCS investing in a lot of
companies that will be winners of a
niche but not really we see cases right
so at some point you have like you had
millions of fundraising before you build
up a structure that's very costly very
inefficient you know use because you
scaled really aggressively you hired a
lot of very expand
people in tech cups and so on and so on
and then you hit like a ceiling and you
kind of like okay to actually break
through we I don't need to completely
pivot we can race for that or we need to
just accept that and just like
continuously do that but like our cost
structure doesn't allow that and I
believe there will be a lot of PE
companies focusing on that hi buying for
example sauce companies like there's
kind tiny capital doing that very
successfully they think three doing that
very successfully like buying sauce
companies either in a certain area or
like in general and then offering the
team to either stay or not their choice
but more importantly replace people
through all remote hires and I'm not
thinking of like cheap outsourcing I'm
thinking more like to run in a
well-defined smaller start-up you don't
need 100 people you know you might only
need a handful of people but those need
to be the best possible people you can
get for that company and for example if
it's a hosting company you know you
might want to get like a few
ridiculously good sis admins where you
know that you know you can hire them one
person over there one person over there
and it's like much easier if you do that
on a global scale you know and you hire
the best possible people for I would say
global rates then hire some random
people that just happened to be in the
same town and charge ridiculous amounts
and I strongly believe that the future
of this kind of private equity at least
is going completely or remote there's
already now companies like think three
who have it's run by the folks who also
do crossover and they have around 3,000
to 4,000 people on the management and
they've been yeah it's a lot and all
remote and the vision of the phone that
there is - at some point I wrecked by a
company every day because you have
infinite supply of ridiculously talented
people who want to work on this kind of
projects right and that will be a big
one another big space I personally see
will help governments go remote
especially around administration and so
on and so on and how do you do that in a
way that's actually secure for a company
or for government and how can you do
that in a way that the companies or
corporations that are notoriously bad
with trusts and processes how can you
help them - basically
learn to trust in this angle here yeah
let's go back to the private equity a
second because to me that that's a
really interesting idea of basically
take a company who either one is not
optimized for remote work but trying or
two they don't haven't even tried yet
and you have two aspects right so if I
buy your company and then I put it into
this model one I can probably
drastically reduce cost right by
hey rather than pay that engineer in San
Francisco I can pay an engineer from
another part of the world they're
getting a great salary given kind of the
cost of living but then to also you're
dropping cost so there's kind of like
what I would consider more of the
mercenary type approach to private
equity where you're stripping out cost
but then there's also another part of it
which is growing right if all of a
sudden I say look I actually not gonna
get rid of any of the employees I want
to keep everyone I currently have but
moving forward as we hire more and more
people I want more resources and I'm
gonna do it on a more cost-effective
basis right and so it's less about
stripping costs at that point and it's
more about turning a company from a
centralized corporation to this remote
work do you think that this is more
about the capital encourage to do it or
do you think that the person or group
who does this is going to be somebody
who's really really familiar with the
processes and the experiences of
building remote teams
so both the angle here is if you have
like first of all you can buy any
company anywhere it doesn't matter where
they are most like you have focused on
certain time zones like the classic one
would be like west coast to Eastern
Europe you know and like Africa Latin
America included you so you hire them
anywhere and you might have people in
your company who just like super
experienced already doing for example
fixing the accounting fixing whatever
typical problems you have at that stage
fixing customer care setup and all this
kind of stuff and they come in and help
setting that up properly and this is
what they enjoy they're kind of like
enjoy this troubleshooting period you
know and we think a lot about like
celery and like costs and it's true like
you can hire cheaper but that's more
because San Francisco and New York is
disproportionately expensive in my
opinion but it's not like cheap
outsourcing as many people think of it
experience talent that's highly
qualified and is able to work online you
know this you it's somebody that you can
actually easily find online will be
somebody who has multiple offers and
there is a market for that you know and
they will expect international salaries
they don't care what the local salary in
Bulgaria or Nigeria or whatever for a
senior engineer would be you know they
expect an international salary so it's
sometimes surprisingly expensive and I
know people who pay for Sanford Eastern
European C's ops people 400 K 500 K you
know and because there's no global
expectation yeah yeah and these are
people who are some of the best and if
you are if you're acquiring these kind
of companies you might want to have some
of the best people joining you it's
almost like a skill based income or
salary versus a geography based yes yes
and no so yes in general yes
I personally I'm always lucky to getting
a little bit of like hate on Twitter for
this but I don't believe in the fact
that everybody should earn the same
salary worldwide okay why on the long
run maybe you know but right now
I strongly believe in decentralized
solutions and the market is a
decentralized solution if there is a
certain market rate for a certain task
skill person that's the market rate and
that things that I strongly believe that
senior engineers
globally are expecting global salaries
so it will be let's say 60 to 160 K
right and that's an expectation they
will have as a senior engineer but
that's nowhere in comparison to you
typical San Francisco salaries for
example and there's very very few teams
that dues salaries on the same scale
that actually hire in ridiculous spaces
like like San Francisco but also in
super low priced areas like Nicaragua or
Nigeria or anywhere else you know they
because it's really hard to keep this
internal balance like it's hard to keep
an internal balance if you do for
example same salary you have somebody in
a in an expensive country who can't just
like move tomorrow you know he can't
just
tell his family that he's moving
somewhere else cheaper or she's moving
somewhere cheaper who works for okay is
living and somebody else who gets the
same seller who buys a flat every year
in cash you know so you put you actually
want to get to it's to the point that
people of comparable experience and
talent have a comparable lifestyle which
is should be ideally off the chart
amazing if they are amazing talent you
know but I do not believe a flat rate
salary in a company can achieve that
that easily unless you really really
aggressively either just believe that
and don't hire many people that's great
or if you limit very actually hire and
you only hire the US and Canada for
example and some Western Europe
countries for sure a lot of teams in
crypto are pretty decentralized and if
of course work based just given the
nature of what they're building because
of the industry etc are there any
companies encrypt or not that you kind
of say look you know from what you see
from the outside you think they're doing
a great job and kind of serve as role
models before for folks listening to
this that they maybe want to kind of
look at how somebody else is doing this
so in in like more the meta level here
what we had like right now companies
like Google and Facebook almost like
remote team in denial they if you if you
happen to work in Google it's very
likely that you don't even seeing the
people you've worked with regularity
outside of a video conference room right
and you may be on the same campus yeah
exactly because it's like no point like
going there it's just too much effort
right so you actually happen to always
see them in a video chat anyway it's
almost like remote team in denial and
any company above I would say 800 people
is like basically set up like a remote
first team usually unless they manage
some magic I don't know about so we have
a lot of the learnings or the patterns
that work in remote teams really well in
these kind of companies and I also
strongly believe that the next
generation of Google's will actually
take a lot of the learnings that come
from decentralized organizations
Dow's and and you name it and take those
learnings because if you have a company
with several thousand people it's almost
like its internal market of decisions
and its internal market of talent and
right now we don't reflect
that we have like very rigid systems and
I strongly believe that there will be
multiple crypto companies that manage to
have learnings here where they were not
what they built but how they build it
will actually be the more interesting
product for other companies to pick up
in do you feel like that's only
applicable to the crypto companies or do
you think that that's applicable outside
of crypto what exactly I mean so like
those learnings you shouldn't specific
crypto companies will be built that way
do you think that no it this will be
like I think some of the biggest
takeaways similar we had to some of the
biggest takeaways from open source we're
really useful for companies that don't
work open-source the same way here how a
lot of these decentralized organizations
actually work will be in some cases more
important than actually what they worked
on and like companies like the next
generation of Google's will actually
take those patterns and apply them they
will have internal systems for decision
like these address systems for
decision-making see centralized systems
for identity or decentralized systems
for talent markets and all this kind of
stuff although the company itself isn't
consider themselves like to work on any
decentralized product mm-hmm what's your
take in terms of if I'm a team and I
want to find somebody who wants to work
remote what are the best practices there
is this let me go and tweet a bunch on
Twitter and hope somebody sees it is
there things that angel is that I should
be using are there other tools I don't I
find that talent or vice versa them to
talent how do I find the companies
they're looking to hire remote mm-hmm so
from the company POV it depends on the
statue all right okay so early stage the
best thing you can do is leverage your
network the good thing is you for
working remote you don't limit to your
network that just happens to be in the
same town right so hire the people that
you trust or people you trust they trust
that's the number one advice for any
startup and I personally believe there's
nothing magical unique to remote work
it's just like right now it's a kind of
tipping point moment for us you know but
that's true in any case for startups
afterwards what I highly recommend is
active reach out so use sourcing tools
like an angel list we have a source or a
list or on LinkedIn there's like
LinkedIn recruit and there's multiple
other tools where you actively can
search for specific kinds of profiles
you know and intentionally
approach those people with a very
consider concise pitch why and what work
why are you doing what you're doing and
what would they be doing you know I have
very good experience of this and the
other one that is completely under
leveraged in my opinion is employer
branding it's when you say like tweet a
bunch right this kind of stuff like
tweeting blogging or just being present
in your community you know is one of the
least leveraged hiring tools that a lot
of companies do if you have a strong
brand and you have the set up that
people can technically work remote from
you you would have more impound and you
can manage because right now there's an
arbitrage more opportunity right now
there's more people wanting to work
remote then there is companies offering
quality remote jobs so if you can
actually leverage this moment right now
you will have an unfair advantage and
like startups are only about unfair
advantage right now on AngelList if you
are opening a drop listing and you open
it up to remote you would have four XD
applicants if you have a good brand you
would have multiple times of that and
you might have it even without posting
it on any job board I know teams that
are 40 people of companies that you have
never heard of who have several hundred
applicants for each job they open and
they usually take down jobs even without
having found anybody just to manage the
inbound
so you basically open up the job for
like one week and then close it again
because we have enough applicants if you
don't find it in this pool of 400 it's
us not them right and so yeah that's my
personal advice here got it what are the
dangers of a remote work right so
everything we're talking about is kind
of the positive impact and the benefits
but are there any dangers that you
foresee or things that people should
should watch out it's kind of like
potholes in the road so personally I
think you need to leverage up a level up
as a manager a lot and that's the
legwork that a lot of teams don't want
to do or can do and it's kind of like
personal limitations where you see
yourself and all this kind of stuff you
need to level up as a manager you need
to be more aware about how you work with
people how you want to work with people
how you do process and all this kind of
stuff that's the biggest mistake that I
constantly see on a more
like what I believe in future might be
an interesting problem and that's not a
I have nobody heard it yet but I this is
kind of like they're boring dystopia I'm
waiting for is fraud in remote work so
you actually hire somebody and that
person turns out not to be the person
that you like that you hired you know
it's actually this person outsources to
somebody else you know or boy I'm
literally waiting for some of my
portfolio companies to tell me that they
had a employee who literally deep faked
video or something like that I'm just
waiting for that I have I know companies
were like one friend of mine he has a
team of like 150 people and there's one
employee who's one of his earliest who
nobody in a team knows how this person
looks like or sounds like they've never
spoken the next super shy person doesn't
want that you know and there's many
reasons most likely for that but
otherwise super happy and engaged in the
team that they've never talked to that
person so it they see it kind of like
from their point of view and in being as
excluding inclusive as they can and I'm
almost like what if this person is
literally not a person but a group of
people who share a celery you know like
this is the kind of dystopian future I'm
waiting for and hoping for in a weird
way but for the moment we are right now
become better managers yeah
it's a really interesting way to look at
it in terms of manager here going back
to what you said earlier about managing
processes and leading people it's by
becoming better process driven and
documentation and and really learning
how to unblock those that you work with
you become that better manager right but
it's almost like the the macro effort is
hey you've got to be a better manager
the micro effort there is very
action-oriented things that look is you
know kind of tedious hard work but if
you do it correctly can be incredibly
empowering for a team there exactly it's
almost it's a remote team you're forced
to do that kind of stuff and there's so
many angles to this there is what a lot
of team do wrong is the whole opinion
versus decisions it's not clear who
actually makes a decision here and
everybody has opinions and it's a lot of
people confuse their own opinion with
like that's actually a decision the
classic one is you have like one
co-founder who is technically not part
of that team but like as their opinion
this is piece of that people don't
follow that so opinion versus decisions
or in general Act decision layering like
who makes what kind of decisions a very
common problem is that inexperienced
that have found us to drive by
management where they focus on problems
that are fun to solve because they're
easy and small instead of focusing the
annoying problems that they are supposed
to do but don't like because they start
they start because they're like
programming and whatever and now they
have to do fundraising and like fixing
whatever board problem you know so in
static jump into a team and do like
drive-by management where to give like a
lot of opinions and decisions Froderman
and then everybody's confused and when
the first question is asked to the
founders already gone you know that
that's a very common anti-pattern I see
sometimes even unintentional just by the
fact that the voice of an founder is has
a lot of weight and especially across
multiple cultures that can be a huge
problem so what a lot of remote teams
actually do for example here is they add
hashtags where they say FYI or
suggestion or recommendation or plea or
request and they have internal wiki page
where it literally says what each of
them mean so if I say this I don't
expect you to do whatever but if I say
that I expect you to do what this one
thing yeah and some of this the nuance
is almost lost right when when you're
not together every single day and so
having that clear communication kind of
strategy almost right and in process
clears up a lot of that what happens
when that breaks down though right like
in terms of like conflict resolution how
have you seen teams who where maybe the
best solution would be let's sit down
face to face and have a conversation you
can't do that because you're
geographically limited
how do those teams do conflict
resolution I wish I would have like a
simple answer to that I think that's
literally the hardest challenge that you
have as a manager it's kind of like
everything is easy but people you know
and as soon as you have multiple people
you have like nxn problems here the
things that ice saw that work is usually
all people in your team come with the
right intentions and they just so it's
much more like it's kind of like person
plus context is output
and usually it's more context problem
that people face and it's more the fact
that something isn't clear it's not
clear who makes the decision it's not
clear how you actually want people to
make decisions where you prioritize know
this kind of stuff so in a lot of cases
is actually the fault of the manager
above and not the actual that people
don't like each other the good thing in
remote teams if you don't like the other
person that much you don't have that
much context area if you don't want to
right so in most cases it's much more
about fixing that context how you make
decisions and like what kind of
decisions are made and if all of that
breaks down like I still recommend like
fly people together there's like a few
problems that can't be fixed if people
meet each other and just actually
understand how they are different and
very often it comes down to cultural
differences like I'm Germanic I give
feedback as direct as you can imagine
you know which in California is
considered borderline autistic you know
so you need to learn the balance in
between sometimes for sure and as part
of this conflict resolution is you
really only have a fairly professional
relationship and if you take remote work
very literally right so you and I the
only times we talk as preset meetings
and then maybe we communicate over slack
and then we might have an asynchronous
meeting or two to like a Google Doc
let's say right so that's the only way
that you and I as two members of a
remote team interact you lose a lot of
the kind of humanity of those that you
work with right or that that personal
relationship if that's all you do
the way that that's solved I think in
terms of a traditional company is you
run into each other the hallway or in
the in the company kitchen you can go
get drinks after work you know that
there's kind of off-site events like
there's all these things that can happen
whether intentionally or not that
provide more of the humanity side of
that personal relationship what have you
seen teams do there even if they can't
get together in person like what are
some of the things that they can do to
just drive deeper personal relationships
and kind of build team if you will so
first I will say something about the
general premise here okay I strongly
believe that you can be very very lonely
and very very isolated in a very full
office oh for sure and you can be very
on
happy in like you can have a very
productive work experience and a
horrible human experience although you
sit next to everybody and I I know
people who are literally lonely although
they sit like you know in a very full
office and that is not like so this is
nothing to select something to do with
remote work it's much more about how the
company of a company culture is set up
okay that's very very point good point
and I also see like a lot of people were
in a remote team where the people
actually have very very strong personal
relationships to each other you know but
not just because this is next to each
other because they intentionally want to
have that so it's kind of like comes it
comes are the angle here what people are
trying to do here to do have like a
little bit more like a human angle there
there's multiple things that that people
are trying and I don't have a perfect
answer for this there is the classic one
is like donut where you just get people
together for like a video chat that's
nothing to do with work there's other
teams that try to do like once a week to
have a discussion that's not nothing you
know and just like get together I know
there's other teams that intentionally
do off sites once a quarter to have this
kind of interaction there is teams that
by everybody my team a Nintendo switch
and have like this like pot that
announces when somebody's playing so
that somebody else can join as well
people are experimenting if there's a
lot right now I don't think there is yet
a magic bullet but I also believe that
there is not really a magic bullet in
offices like a lot of these things that
we do we kind of cargo cult it in like
like office I don't know in Helloween
everybody comes stressed you know and
like everybody has like a funny whatever
and that's terrifying to me personally
for example as a dramatic person you
know so I think we're still learning
here and also like in remote teams like
people still learning this yeah makes
sense which thoughts on Bitcoin in Korea
I actually looked up when I bought my
first Bitcoin before I came here okay
let's let's say it like this I instantly
received afterwards an email by coinbase
that I bumped up my daily allowance to
buy Bitcoin I think like 260 BTC per day
or something like that I think the first
Bitcoin I bought at like $70 and the
next Avenue
I think so and the next one it like runs
rehung greenish I think I horrible
horrible decisions yeah so I remember
back then I was living in Berlin and a
friend of mine basically pushed me to
you to buy Bitcoin and I was like yeah
cool I'd do that but I literally don't
have the money to buy food you know and
so maybe food is more important and I
only buy like a little bit of Bitcoin
looking back I'm quite fat nowadays you
know I could have just like bought less
food and bought bought more Bitcoin back
then personally like I have a long take
on on crypto because obviously like we
all work in this industry in the summer
angle but I'm personally still super
bullish on multiple decentralized
solutions and I still believe there's
like a lot to come and we are almost
like generation zero yet and we there
was like a disproportional media hype
around it and I what I personally like
now is that we're in a phase where
people are almost like shut up and get
back to work and I honestly believe
right now is kind of like generation one
almost like we're getting not to a point
where a lot of more interesting
companies are popping up yeah it almost
feels like 20 years from now we'll look
back and people be like you you guys are
doing what right and an example that
that I actually recently wrote about
this I went back and I screenshot a
bunch of the early consumer web websites
you know Netscape Amazon etc and even
things like you know URLs compared to IP
addresses yeah right and today if you
look at like digital wallets with these
you know random string of letters and
numbers but eventually that can get
solved with something that's more you
know human readable if you will I
honestly still believe that it's
offensive that I have a telephone number
why I mean this is an obvious like why
do I have a telephone number like
there's millions of solutions for that
nowadays and I have a freaking telephone
number this is like having an IP address
for my website this bizarre and more
importantly which is complete it breaks
completely
down because so many apps actually
relying on are you having a telephone
number and when you switch them
regularly as international people tend
to do you pretty much a screwed unless
you lose in Google Voice or something so
yeah we will look back at the current
generation almost like as we look back
to the times before the first comm even
before the first comp I think for sure
and then outside of Bitcoin any thoughts
there or mainly your focus is on Bitcoin
and the decentralized companies so for
me the three things I'm personally super
bullish on and and I'm not technically
experts and everybody listening to this
is an expert I'm I meant by standing
person that was given a microphone my
personal opinion here is Bitcoin because
of the brand and the public recognition
multiple other coins because of privacy
drugs and everything else and I am
personally super bullish on markets of
markets so basically saying there will
be always commodity resources that will
have providers with spare capacities
that will sell on their own marketplace
and that an easy example like an easy
example to frame this would be love
example storage it's like a classical
one right so you have all these
providers who have their own storage
capacity and selling it on their own
marketplace and there will be spare
capacity that they will sell on
decentralized
markets of markets so basically a market
place for like a market were
intentionally it set up that nobody can
actually screw the system and nobody can
skew the system once they get like
critical amount and there is solutions
nowadays and encrypted trying to do that
like five coins on like it would be
solutions otherwise in in future and
that's where I'm personally most bullish
on because this is nothing where you
have to consumer facing angle the
promise of consumer facing angle is
always you will have somebody kneeling
down doing brand and doing marketing and
UX and UI and that person can at some
point skew the market again yeah I think
you're right in terms of again goes back
to process right process inside the
company can set you up for success or
set you up for failure see
with these marketplaces decentralized
corporations etc is it's almost like
they'll preset the rules and if they're
thoughtful about how they do that they
could prevent a lot of the bad stuff
from happening that that I think people
are worried about right now
mm-hmm right it's it's I I strongly
believe that sociology game theory
systems theory we would not yet include
enough of this in how we think about
business for sure before we wrap up I
always ask us some rapid-fire questions
what do you think is the most important
company in crypto in crypto I I would
like to ask you this I'm not an investor
actually Bitcoin yeah like if you
consider Bitcoin a company yeah
definitely even even for anything just
for the brand recognition yeah because
my mother knows Bitcoin for sure and
that's worth something
you want to hear a wild story about
mom's and Bitcoin okay my but my mom
knows that you know I'm into Bitcoin
doesn't really kind of fully understand
it whatever and the other day Bitcoin
crashed two days in a row almost ten
percent both days so true dowry
aggressively and I got a message on the
second day from my mother that said I
want to buy some Bitcoin how do I do
that and so I immediately called her
just said what are you doing we talking
about and she said well I figure it's on
sale nice and I literally was like she
may be smarter than like 90% of crypto
you know Twitter or something right a
bit quite Twitter and I kept talking to
her about it she goes well like she's
like everyone is saying how the price is
going down she goes when you buy clothes
when the price goes down then you want
to buy them and I just sat there and I
had literally was amazed she knows
nothing about investing you know in
terms of the the car traditional
investing or anything but it was just
this mentality of it's almost like the
the ignorance that she had to the price
movements and all this stuff was the
drawdown was so severe that it kind of
made the more mainstream news which is
things that she would look at and when
that happened she thought like oh I
should buy one now while they're cheap
and it reminded me that was it in 2017
at the at the top of the market she also
asked me one if I'd give her one for
Christmas so there's only two times my
brother and I've ever talked about
Bitcoin and what it was at the the top
of the market in 2017 for Christmas and
the second time was after like a 20%
rata you trying to get off thought of
this question but did you give it I did
not give her a Bitcoin what are you
giving your mother this year for
Christmas I haven't decided yet but it's
not going to be a Bitcoin it is not
gonna be a Bitcoin in the thought
process you can use no it's more of she
it's soft preservation cachet called me
every day because she would watch the
price right and then call me and say
what's going on and so if if I don't
give her one then I'm not the person
that she's gonna call if she has a
Bitcoin so if she buys it on her own
then she'll have herself to question I
cannot watch the price every day like
like how does she do that like a mother
has like a isn't today yeah yeah the
last thing you want is your mother to be
stressed I will stress what stress would
not be the the biggest concern basically
sure of this you keep calling me asking
me questions what what's the most
important book you've ever read the most
important book yeah there's a lot of
them I know you read a lot you gotta
pick one or two oh yeah yeah so first of
all if people try to get into reading
one thing I would highly recommend this
don't read all this business BS books
there's so many books to tell you about
something whatever and it's it's always
like a hi book of the day usually it's
very very hard to use those to get into
reading what I highly recommend is pick
something that you're passionate about
and that's basically almost like I don't
know she that's interesting yeah but
like almost like how do you call like a
habit you're ashamed of you know like
something like where you're kind of like
dirty secret kind of you know so I read
a ton of sci-fi okay and it can be from
horrible military sci-fi that's written
by somebody who is obviously doesn't
like young people you know up to
completely beasts are sci-fi about
complex interstellar systems that are
doing whatever crazy stuff that's hard
to articulate up to a multi-dimensional
cipher like just like cyberpunk whatever
you know like you name it space operas
and so on and so on like I love sci-fi
this is what I read most if I would
recommend two books that I think
everybody should read and the most
influential book for me was how to win
friends and influence people and I you
know it's almost like to the point that
I almost like it should be given to
people that kind of like you have a
driving licence test but to become a
human and it's almost like you should
read that to get like your license to be
allowed to interact with other people
and it almost felt back to me when I
first time read it I was like oh [ __ ]
I'm a horrible person and I'm like I
also realized how horrible I was as a
first-time founder like how much of my
own problems I just put on other people
and like how horribly interacted with
people so that's a book I almost
recommend everybody to read and a part
of that I can talk about forever about
this like if you if you are one our
interesting takes on politics right now
I the dictators handbook ism ISM gives
you like an interesting angle to think
of politics in a game theory POV the
idea is kind of like why do politics
happen the way they happen and although
it's like we think it's wrong you know
and we think these people are doing
something bad and whatever because it
works in their game and highly recommend
that one I have a ton of books like that
all right one more
NACO economics how drug cartels operate
and that's all of them intentionally are
books that are fun to read none of them
is like a drag to read you know you can
read like there's millions of books that
like like high growth performance or why
we sleep and all these kind of books
like books important to read you know
but these are poops that are you can
read them for fun and you don't need to
learn anything and it will be still like
good good for you to read like amazing
theory narco economics is one where it
explains how knock-knock
cartels basically operate and how the
actual economics behind it I've operate
and how little the like or how
counterintuitive
the effects are of people things that we
do to stop it and how little it actually
matters so for example if you burn down
most of the for example in cocaine the
coca leaf fields which was like very
common practice in Venezuela or Colombia
and so on and so on it has almost no
effect on the price because it doesn't
matter what happens is that just more
farmers are forced to do it you know
before once on all right if you if you
block them at the border it doesn't
matter for the price the price almost
doesn't change for these kind of stuff
because the whole how do you economics
are set up to the point that it's
something like cocaine if it would be
legal would be something that I think
it's comparable to a premium coffee in
price something like that you know it's
it's ridiculous like it's almost like
the more you destroy it probably the
price goes up obviously yeah how much
made more hurdles you throw in it like
it goes very well into the systems
theoretic concepts behind it and what's
happening around that so like that's one
I highly recommend and there's like
multiple more if you wanna like talk
sci-fi I can't talk forever aliens
speaking a sci-fi believer and
non-believer there's nothing to believe
woody me it's statistically impossible
that there is no other life out there
and it's almost like a given fact that
we already know not even mean I think
yeah whatever it is like on a life in
general like organic life in general
it's almost like a given fact this
exists intelligent life is statistically
impossible it doesn't exist given the
scale on the universe like I think we
are human or just we cannot comprehend
how big the universe actually is and we
cannot complex it's for us to just our
brain doesn't work on that scale our
brain doesn't work the same as we cannot
handle exponential scale factors not as
kind of stuff we cannot comprehend how
big the universities so there is no
question if there's intelligent life out
there or not you know it feels to me
like I always go to the ocean first
right so we can't comprehend how vast
and deep the ocean is let alone space
right like the ocean is nothing compared
to just that our solar system let alone
the you know the galaxies etc and most
humans camera
her head around the ocean and so it's
like on such a minut scale the ocean
well of course they can't think of space
yeah right all they think about is like
what's the next planet next to us right
they think of this our next-door
neighbor how come we can't get there if
a fascinating thing here is humans don't
think of distance as like a unit of
distance they think of it as a unit of
time so for example America used to be
far away
the Wild West used to be far away and
the more we had like it was becoming
more and more normal we had different
chips we had railroads and so on and so
on it becomes like more accessible from
like months and years to get to the
other side two days and two-hour like
later on two hours the same is true in
space right now it's for us in
comprehendible to do used to be
incompatible to go to the Mars nowadays
it's becoming like an achievable thing
if different systems in future either
different rocket systems or different
other setups likes like sky hooks and so
on and so on you name it it will be
short and shorter time and to the point
that we think of distance as time the
problem we have though still is even if
all of this currently foreseeable
futures in technology work it's still
the next solar system is still
uncompromising well the thing I'll say
is in the United States if yes I mean
how far away is that right so it's I
said do you know how far away is another
part of Manhattan Americans would answer
in time Yeah right in moments - yeah
well and the only places where you know
my girl or fiancee now is from Bulgaria
right and much closer to where you're
from there's still a lot of people who
answer in kilometers right and so it's
very funny because they assume a certain
transportation buddy hope yes and so
it's in the u.s. you can't do that right
because you don't know it alone so we
get to get camera you can take the
subway or they'll walk et cetera in
other parts of the world you you have to
assume right and so it's just
interesting even here on earth when you
ask people simple question like how far
is that place you get different types of
answers like like the structure they use
is different which obviously changes
when you start getting into space and
for success I think the best example for
this is la la it's almost like this
thing where space and time don't work
the same way as everywhere else
something is really close on a map and
you need to get there forever in a car
because a traffic jam is so bad I know
to get back to the original topic for a
second like I know remote teams that
only hire in LA but they're fully remote
like small teams though you know but it
no actually four of them and all of them
like ten or less people and they
consider themselves a fully remote team
but everybody's in LA because it's just
too much pain to actually go to the same
areas last time yes right this is kind
of the the promise of autonomous
vehicles etc so can we free pickup that
creative time etc to wrap up I always
let somebody asked me a question what
one question do you have for me I wanted
to ask you when are you going to propose
but I failed by like one week I thought
two weeks now what is the craziest thing
that you think you can get through at
your wedding with your wife that you can
actually pull off that she's okay with
that still will potentially blow
everybody mind because I know it you
have 425 ideas and like I did four of
them I legally five of them are like
borderline dangerous and like it a rest
is like forbidden by your wife a future
so she made the mistake and told me that
one of the Bulgarian traditions at some
weddings and there's this whole gypsy
non-gypsy you know all the stuff in
Bulgaria but one of the traditions is
that they have a live dancing bear and
so for me
I don't know if I can pull it off in the
US but at some point in the celebrations
whether it's actually a act the wedding
after the wedding a celebration in
Bulgaria etc I think I can get a bear
there and if I can get a bear then I
feel like that anchors you on if you
have a live dancing bear
had an event there's a whole bunch of
other things you can do that don't look
as ridiculous as having a bear and so
that's probably the one that I'm focused
on at the moment because you know how
could a beautiful woman from Bulgaria I
turned down a Bulgarian tradition I
don't think it's that hard to get a
barony so you're that kind of stuff that
what you need to make sure it's like it
humane treatment and all this kind of
stuff I think that's will be harder I
have been to poor Gary and weddings and
now you're choking and I think there
will be like a few listeners from the
Balkans here like a lot of time I guess
Balkan weddings are next level you know
and I think they're I think Indian
weddings are crazy but Balkan weddings
are basically Indian weddings with like
too much alcohol and like completely
crazy you know my favorite part of that
entire part of the world is there's one
mentality that just every time I hear it
just cracks me up and it's at some point
at an event they say okay get rid of the
alcohol and go get the beer and the wine
that's right they talk about getting rid
of the liquor and then getting beard why
and to me the first I ever heard and I
just started dying laughing it's excuse
me I have like when I grew up I had like
Russian family friends who's who said
that they started the quendi came to
rest of like a Western Europe they were
actually excited about finally drinking
healthy drinks like beer so yeah it's a
it's a thing I love it oh if I get a if
I get a bear to to any event as part of
these festivities then then I'll be
happy so let's see what I can pull off
personally I'm super excited about your
wedding and I'm super excited about the
fact that you're doing a Bulgarian
wedding a proper one and I most super
excited you still don't comprehend what
you're getting into with this and I hope
that somebody in your fiance's family is
actually taking this as like basically a
wild card to go all out bonkers and just
like freaky odd about this not only is
somebody in her family I'm sure she's
doing the same thing so we're gonna see
how this plays out but I think we are
probably gonna end up having to two
separate events one of the United States
and one in Bulgaria the something tells
me the Bulgarian ones I wanna come to
the Bulgarian
you care about the US and one if it's
close to any book area wedding I have
been too good like it maybe as well do
so I have open invite anyone who can
make it the Bulgaria could come yeah
honestly all right man listen thank you
so much for coming in and thanks for
coming this I think a lot of people
gonna find the super valuable and then
we'll have to do it again as as you kind
of continue to go down this path of
remote work and the work in angellist
cool thanks for having me sure